you
good morning everybody thank you for
coming sort of bright and early if this
is your first session of the morning my
name is Roy Zimmerman and I'm delighted
to have you all here today to see some
of the exciting things happening in
Microsoft Research this will be an
opportunity for you to go a bit deeper
than what you might be able to see or
learn about these particular projects
during the research showcase later today
so it's a really good opportunity to get
a deeper understanding of some of some
of the most exciting things happening in
Microsoft Research in my opinion first
we've got Jonathan protank Oh with
Microsoft Research Jonathan's research
interests revolve around type systems
and programming languages design and
implementation last year he worked with
the BBC to deliver a million that's
about yeah about a million micro bits to
every school in the United Kingdom to
help seventh graders learn programming
through these machines so it's a
national rollout of these machines that
were developed and refined specifically
to tell to help 12 year olds learn how
to a computer program so with that I'm
going to hand the floor over to you well
thanks Roy for the introduction so as
we're mentioned this ladies and
gentlemen is the future of cs education
this is a BBC micro bit it's half the
size of a credit card and there's about
a million school kids that just get one
for free in the united kingdom because
they want to learn about programming so
in this talk I'm going to tell you a
little bit more about the whole project
why we're doing it the larger CS
education trend that's happening and the
way Microsoft has helped the project
mature and come to what we hope is going
to be a success so this really cute
picture is from the 1980s and this girl
is playing on her TV screen with a big
machine that's a big computer from the
80s in the computer is called a BBC
micro so you have to remember that in
the 1980s there were a lot of these
first personal microcomputers the one
the top left corner is a Commodore two
on the right are sinclair ZX and the one
on the bottom left is BBC micro and the
thing that's really amazing when you go
to the UK is that a lot of people work
in computer science nowadays tell you oh
the way I got started with for grabbing
with with the BBC micro so a lot of
people who are nowadays big people in
computer science people who work at our
and people who work at Microsoft they
all remember how he got started and the
guys started because they had a BBC
micro arm the company originally was
called a corn an acorn was a company
that manufactured the BBC micros the BBC
micro had a massive impact in the UK in
the 1980s and this is a funny picture
that I'd like to show this is not a
hipster from Brooklyn it's an actual
person from the 1980s and it's I and one
of the original designers of the pbc
micro but the BBC micro had perhaps one
problem it was relatively expensive for
its day it meant that schools had one
BBC micro that people could buy one if
they wanted to but it was usually it'll
be too expensive for the average
household so a lot of people will tell
you well my dad with a schoolteacher and
well we managed to sneak the BBC micro
for the summer holidays and that's how I
learned to program so the BBC wants to
renew that enthusiasm they want to renew
the phenomenon they want to do the BBC
micro again but this time they want to
make it more affordable and they want to
make sure that every kid has one for
free and that's called the BBC micro bit
so really that's what I just said the
vision is repeat the BBC micro impact
Sodor the BBC is running a massive
advertising campaign the only thing they
advertise more is the Olympics so you've
had product placement in many BBC TV
programs there's been a lot of stars
including well I am Who Played with the
micro bit so really they're growing big
for this we even made the cover of Wired
that was a big moment for us
so let's talk a little bit about the
technical details the BBC micro bit is a
small personal coding device so that
means that you own it you can store it
in your pocket there's different ways to
look at it the first one is a way to
learn programming it's more fun to have
something that you can hold in your hand
to learn about things and if you are
more advanced the BBC micro bit you can
go beyond very simple programs and you
can use it just like you would use an
Arduino you can connect it to
temperature sensors 7-segment displays
cold storage devices if you want there's
a lot of extension pins at the bottom of
the connector so really there's a wide
range of applications so let me tell you
a little bit about the exciting hardware
specifications so there's wade through
it 16k of RAM which is an impressive
number for such a small device and it's
packed with features there's an
accelerometer a comp ass there's a
temperature sensor there's a processor
that has bluetooth capabilities so you
can connect it to your phone there's a
lot of output rings on the edge
connectors you can connect any i2c
display you can power it using a pack of
batteries so there's a lot of
applications the application that we
think is going to be the most successful
is you use it as a selfie stick you
connect it to your phone you put your
phone trigger with the micro bit I don't
have the demo right now but that's
typically one of the applications that
you can think of one important thing
that I want to highlight is that the
processor is a very standard ARM
processor so if you're like a super
advanced kid and say you want to program
using C++ then you can definitely use
the tools that you know for instance GCC
and you can compile programs using GCC
for that device so a question that I get
often is why you want to create a new
device every kid has a smartphone they
could learn programming under smartphone
well there's a difference the first one
is pilot studies have repeatedly shown
that it's much more fun to have a device
that you can hold in your hand that you
can have in your pocket and if you can
show around with your friends
the second reason is if you do a hello
world program your smartphone it's going
to take you two weeks to set up the
toolchain the development of our amount
and after two weeks what you're going to
do is you're going to have a terrible
terrible hello world program that's Luke
that looks awful compared to all the
other nice programs you have on your
smartphone that's very discouraging so
with that device there's no such
phenomenon everything you do is fun and
you can do as as like programs just like
your other classmates and the last
reason is it's extremely inexpensive the
price range would be in ballpark ten
dollars and there's a phenomenon which
is that if you have an expensive
smartphone or even a computer you're
afraid to tinker with it it's expensive
maybe you're in a low-income household
and you don't want to break it it's a
precious piece of hardware so you're
very cautious and you're afraid to
tinker with the device with that one you
can solder you can try stuff you can
throw it around it's basically
unbreakable I've been carrying that one
in my pocket for a while it's and it's
cheap it's no big deal if you break it
so really you can experiment and there's
a lot more engagement and as I mentioned
previously you can connect it using the
i/o pins on the edge you can connect it
using bluetooth so really it's a gateway
for even more advanced projects that is
the website and I'm going to demo to you
right now how to write a program for the
BBC micro bridge that you can see how
easy it is a demo time
all right my display is cloned and I can
go to the BBC micro bit website okay so
that's the website from the BBC if I hit
this button I'm going to jump it to a
programming environment that we
developed at microsoft research so that
is our contribution to the project
that's the programming environment that
you use to write programs for the BBC
micro bit and well the reason I work on
it is because I like programming
languages that's kind of my trade so it
was very happy to try to design a
programming language for kids so let me
try okay this one says Latin demo let's
edit it it's loading alright so it's a
very simple program I did a little bit
earlier it says when you press button a
show LEDs so the device has a grid of 25
LEDs and two buttons that's the main
starting point if you on write a program
so that's typically the equivalent of
the hell world it says when the button
is pressed showed that led pattern and
where the button be is pressed show that
other LED pattern so I can run the
program in my browser and it's running
the simulator so if you want to try out
your program before you flash it to the
microbe it you can do so in your web
browser so I pressed the button a and it
displays the happy face LED pattern if I
press the button be if i press the
button be it displays the sad face LED
pattern I can try to change the LED
pattern just that you can see that i'm
not kidding run again press button be
and the LED pattern changed so that's
that kind of the typical workflow you
plug blocks one into another you run
your program on the simulator and then
what happens is you can compile your
program what you get instantaneously is
a browser download I can hit show in
folder I get a hex file called micro bit
lat
demodex I drag and drop that microbe
it's what okay so the thing is blinking
you can see it let me try to show it on
my screen it's blinking because it's
being reprogrammed now the light has
stopped blinking focus focus yes okay
and now i'm going to run this program on
the micro bit i'm going to press the
button a happy face i'm going to press
the button be set face and that's how
you program the back of the backrub it
once you're done programming it once
you're done flashing it opitz your face
I should probably switch back okay
better once you're done programming the
microbeads you can unplug it and then
you can power it with the battery pack
if you want or you can take it around
and the program persists so that's
really super simple so one key
difference is that in a lot of cases
when you have an Arduino you have to
install a lot of software to reflash the
device this device is very smart when i
plug it in look at the bottom right
corner it pretends to be a USB key so
the thing masquerades as a USB key it
appears in the file explorer just like a
USB Drive and when I copy and paste the
file to it it looks like i'm copy
pasting something onto a USB key but
what happens under the hood is that the
device is reflashed with their new
program and that's super easy and that's
the reason why the thing works in
schools because in schools there's no
way you're going to get every school IT
administrator in the UK to install a
development kit or some device drivers
observe or some tool chain this requires
zero installation just need a web
browser and it works everywhere so
that's the cool thing let me show you
something else this is what we call the
block editor it's very easy a lot of
kids love it it's in the style of
scratch it's a popular paradigm that
like blocks into another you have a
bunch of blocks show ad DS show screen
unbutton pressed you can read the
compass heading to temperature the
acceleration you can even sense the
light level if you want
you can do control flow loops if then
else you can do a little bit of math you
can even play some music but you have to
use crop clips to connect it to speaker
but I had an intern last summer right
Indiana Jones so that it could play it
for demos so you can do a lot of things
but if you want to make a progression
and jump into something that's more
sophisticated you can hit that magical
convert button which ensure you're very
intrigued by and it says hey look at
that we took your blocks program and we
converted it into something that more
closely resembles an actual programming
language so there is no conversion that
says hey that's the grown-up version of
your code do you want to edit it I say
well yes certainly please allow me to
edit my code and here's the other editor
that we offer which is called touch
develop it's a language that's designed
for kids it's very easy to edit but it's
a little bit more sophisticated than the
blocks language it looks like a regular
I don't know simplified dialect of
Pascal you have let me try to add
something so i can add a new line above
this and i can say show string all right
i'm gonna it's touch friendly too so i'm
going to touch it with my finger show
screen a string and when i say hello let
am alright so that editor is a little
bit more advanced you get more api's you
get more libraries to do things you can
write reusable libraries such as
microwave microwave microwave music so
you know we envision that more advanced
kids are going to use this programming
environment to write more sophisticated
larger programs and of course if you're
like the whiz kid you're welcome to use
C++ but I definitely would not recommend
them all right let's demo I'm going to
compile this program written using the
touch develop language and I'm going to
reflash it
onto the device okay the converted one
goes on to the micro bit switching to
the camera app it's blinking because
it's being reprogrammed okay and
hopefully something should happen there
you go hello all right so that's how you
write programs for the microwave let me
go back to my slides shift f5 all right
so that was the DEMA so to recap what
I've just demonstrated we start with
your blog editor script you plug blocks
into another it's very fun you write a
moderately complex program then if you
wish to you can compile it to touch
develop and have a more grown-up program
actually that's always what happens when
you compile it then we have a compiler
directly from touch develop to arm
executable machine code that happens
directly in your browser that's why it
was so fast with directly compiled in
browser touch develop script into an arm
executable so we get our machine code we
glue the arm machine code with some arm
runtime code that's pre-compiled we have
some sort of mini operating system for
the micro bit so we glue the mini
operating system that's written in c++
and s precompile and we stash it along
with the code that was just generated in
the browser there's a little bit more
complexity related to toolkit that's
provided by aren't but that's
unnecessary for the moment and once you
get your arm binary the user can copy it
to the micro bit drive and there you go
you have in your program so as I showed
you there's a lot of blocks there's a
lot of features that the microbe it can
do there's even radio you can send
unstructured radio messages from one
micro bit to another so it's really a
lot of fun but another important bit is
that it works on every single device
that is able to write to a USB key that
means the Chromebook a Mac a tablet or
regular desktop computer so really it's
written it runs in a web browser you saw
that I used chrome from a demo
so it's nothing that's really windows
specific or PC specific it's something
that works everywhere for every kid and
there is no prerequisite except having a
modern up-to-date web browser the kids
love it we've run many experiments in
the UK they're having great fun they're
doing projects they're doing tablet
coding they're doing it of scenarios and
even that person on the Left who happens
to be my CEO happen to like it very much
I heard through the grapevine that he
was more interested in micro bit than
his next meeting so really everyone is
having fun adults included and we also
get press coverage and we even sent what
some school in the UK sent a microbe it
to space so that's a pretty fun
experiment actually wish I could have
done that instead of writing code for
the micro bit all right people have been
selling kits so that's even better we're
really hoping this would happen and it
actually happened people are now selling
you like robots inventors kids things
that you can plug onto your micro bit to
create awesome demos so it just works
you can code you can make you can
connect it and you even get it's a great
device to enable a good CS computer
science curriculum alright so this I've
actually said it before so we can skip
the learning progression I've shown it
as well so I talked about it during the
demo the two programming environments
our I could talk about it a little bit
more the blog editor has no syntax
errors so it's impossible to create a
program that doesn't work everything
works except when you do something
horrible like you try to mix types in
the same variable but that's really a
corner case touch develop is a little
bit more sophisticated you have global
and local variables and more importantly
touch develop s types so you will get a
little bit of syntax errors in a little
bit of typing errors all right here's a
few examples of hardware projects that
people have been doing the microbe it
watch the top right corner is the
ultimate fashion accessory in my lab
have a colleague who wears it all the
time it looks very good the buzzer alarm
is also very simple to do to make a
buzzer you just buy a two dollar piezo
and you're connected using crack clips
to the micro bit and then you have a
function that says generate sinus wave
on the pin and that generates sound and
if you do it that 440 Hertz then well
then you get an A and you can do a
buzzer there's the car that you can
control so it's a lot of fun this in the
top right corner is one project that one
of my interns did let summer it's a
two-player micro bit pong so you have
your pedal which is 1 pixel wide and you
have another pixel which is the ball and
the pixel crosses from one micro bit to
another and goes onto your screen and
then you have to move the paddle very
fast and send it back and as I mentioned
you can actually pair it on to a
smartphone all right the headphones oh
and one last project is very fun is that
always works with kids is the banana
keyboard so you connect a banana to pin
number zero you connect the orange to
ground and then when you touch both with
your hands there's a voltage drop that
can be measured by the microbe it so the
resistance of your body is slightly
smaller than the resistance of the pool
up on the micro bit so it means that the
voltage drops when you hold the orange
and the banana and you can detect that
on the micro bit and then you can play a
sound so you can do to
22 as soon as you hit the banana it's
always great but when you've been on the
demo stand for two hours it's not that
great after all all right the last thing
I'm going to talk about before I'm
kicked out of the stage is education the
UK has realized that computer science is
just not about monkeying around on a
keyboard in front of a computer screen
there is not only a craft but also a
science behind it's just like math you
can do arithmetic that you can also
learn about mathematics and they're
going big they haven't added it to the
cs curriculum in the united kingdom and
they want to teach computer programming
to every kid so the microbe it is a
great support device to do that it
allows you to not only learn how to
fiddle with a computer how to write a
very simple program and have fun but
it's also a great support material for
more advanced theoretical lessons so we
also wrote a bunch of lessons that
teachers can use as a support material
to get started with their class so we
not only did the programming environment
but we also engaged with the teachers we
ran a bunch of pilots in Seattle and we
have like some bass lessons that allow
you to learn about testing algorithms
etc etc etc we even printed out a quick
start guide for teachers so Microsoft is
not only providing the technological
thing but it's also engaging with
teachers and believe it or not we're
also engaging with a lot of other people
we've been working with Lancaster
University with armed with the
manufacturer and everything that we did
is actually open source the runtime
system the OS with micro bit is open
source the touch develop environment
that I showed you is open source and the
BBC is a bit freaked out about
intellectual property but they committed
to publishing the hardware design of the
PCD of the board open source when this
school year is over so when the school
year is over the design of the board
will be available freely and people will
be able to manufacture their own boards
if they wish
do so alright so i think i'm running out
of time the message that i'm going to
say is it's a project that we did in
collaboration with other people we
collaborated with BBC obviously but with
samsung for the android app with arm for
the operating system with University of
Lancaster they wrote a bunch of the
runtime system the code is open source
you can download it you can run that
website log locally you can play with it
you can get a copy of the operating
system and write super specific device
if you're a guru all of that is possible
we are committed to education we're
engaging with academics or providing
lessons booklets and support materials
and we're hoping that this is just the
first step towards a lot more ambitious
CS initiatives I have a booth this
afternoon so you could definitely should
definitely stop by if you want to see
the microbe it play with it and even
touch it thank you thanks Jonathan we
have a few minutes that we can use to
take a few questions if anybody has
questions we won't have time at the end
of course Jonathan and John and Dave
will be around and available if you want
to follow up with conversations but if
anybody has a question we could take
that now yeah
I'm sorry but why did you choose with
lads instead of screen Oh a screen would
have been much more expensive and names
of money and power both so the runtime
system the OS actually does something
very smart it blinks the LEDs at a very
high frequency which means that with
persistence of vision it looks like the
LEDs are on all the time but they're
actually on a very small fraction of the
time and that way you can keep the
microbe it's running on batteries for
almost a month I think thank you yeah hi
thanks very representation I've run a
program for a science program for kids
during this summer is it possible to buy
some micro beads to to implement them on
our program so the BBC has committed to
allowing other people to sell the macro
bit once the school year is over so the
school year is going to end this summer
like maybe july or something and after
that other people will be free to
manufacture and sell the macro bit so
you can expect to see macro bits on
retail for the general public at the
next start of the school year maybe next
number or something I don't have any
concrete information but I know that
it's going to happen and we'll the price
point be about 10 US dollars that's what
I'm hoping for I am NOT looking at these
discussions there's a little bit of
confidential negotiations and things so
sorry nobody I think I imagine that it's
going to be something in that yellow
park somewhere between 10 and a thousand
dollars probably but any any last
questions no okay all right um the
simulation to book it can be used
already yes you can go to the website
dubbed up the microbe it co uk let's see
you that UK and you can play with the
simulator you can even compile your
programs except you won't have a device
to run them
make sure that you can play in the
browser excellent thank you